Speaker 1: In the meantime, Marjorie Taylor
GREENE is becoming Donald Trump's latest attack
dog against Ron DeSantis. Yesterday I told you
about Carrie Lake going after DeSantis in service
of Trump. Now it is Marjorie Taylor. GREENE What
Carrie Lake and Marjorie Taylor GREENE have in
common is they both seem to be openly vying to be
Donald Trump's vice presidential choices. Here's
Marjorie Taylor. GREENE Also attack. Backing to
Santos for where he is announcing his campaign,
which he did last night on Twitter spaces.
Speaker 3: You don't announce that you're
running for president of the
United States in some kind
of little Twitter world. It's not a
real world. Twitter is not real. So
I can't comprehend why that would be the
place to do the announcement. It makes no
sense. I think it's just it's not serious.
Speaker 1: Okay. So Marjorie Taylor GREENE
says DeSantis isn't serious. Remember that there
are there is the belief that Trump will pick a
woman to be his running mate this time around.
The four women whose names are being floated are
Marjorie Taylor GREENE, Carrie Lake, Nikki Haley,
who's running against Trump, and Kristi Noem from
South Dakota, who it's not even clear if she's
interested, and it's not even really clear if
she's the top contender. So arguably, Marjorie
Taylor GREENE participating in this in service
to supporting her own potential candidacy to be
Donald Trump's vice president. A wild 24 hours.
All of these clips will be on our Instagram,
which you can find by searching Instagram for
David Parkman show. They'll be on our Tik Tok
and they will be on our YouTube channel as well.